hey welcome to Australian comte's for
the how to trains your dragons jig over
at that's Joestar that's Dan Merle if we
watch the show for how to train a dragon
then come back here for some insight
some analysis if you stick around to the
end some deleted scenes its new studio
boys change the setting a whole new look
what's old is new we're on our third set
for this show poor thing yeah yeah crazy
right and this will change again as
we're looking for our permanent home
yeah so don't get used to it kids but
the how to trains your dragons Joe
you're a big fan of these movies why you
like both of them I only like first one
really like first disgust I also like
the second one okay I think it up the
spit ups the stakes it expands the world
in a nice way without just being like
it's the same but more even though a
kind of both the animation is much
better it's shot beautifully Roger
Deakins oversaw the cinematography I
think that that's really cool yeah I
just like these movies I also like cats
and he's like a big cat and he's like a
big cat I think that the first one is
lovely it's a contained kind of
father-son story and I'm also a boy and
his dog story and I like both of those
and they they kept it tight and it was
charming and the animation looked great
and then the second one like you said
more and expanded it was so much more
and they expanded it so much became
about like dragon wars and dragon
logistics and stuff like that and it
kind of lost dragon the dragon lore is
pretty the dragon world like really
piled thick and then it kind of lost
that kind of grounding relationship
because he and his dad and a lot of
sequels do this it just kind of resets
the relationship like no one actually
did learn their lesson from the first
movie now he's back to not listening and
like come on
I'm sure but altogether too it's
definitely beautiful he has a flame
sword yeah because again in defense that
was cry like those inventions yeah his
inventions are cool might be create this
I don't like that the mom becomes like a
damsel the moment stoic is back in her
life because she's a badass when you
first see her she's got that crazy like
alright here's the thing about that mom
she saw a dragon in an act of charity
not murder a baby uh-huh very low bar to
cross the dragon didn't murder the baby
yeah like like trees boyfriend yes
very low bar for her too then without
saying anything take off in the night
abandon her child and husband yeah just
disappear because she had an inkling
that Dragons might not be so bad after
all there's a big step from realizing
that to completely ghosting on your
entire family well you know she was real
happy with stoic the whole Viking thing
nowhere in my critique did I say she's a
good mother she's a very bad one mm very
bad mom man it's very cool armor
yeah and they stoic is clearly willing
to let bygones be bygones because it's
like ah still like the tribal chief
we're not the knee deep and replacement
cate blanchett moved on can you replace
cate blanchett well no but he wouldn't
people to try this what I'll say I
probably did but they've got their own
little shallow duet and it works well I
don't think you'd still be carrying the
ax I think a little more pissed yeah
there's one of those dumb and dumber
movements that moment you and
then you totally redeem yourself
so anyways mixed for me it's mixed I
like it would be weird in the children's
movie if they got real like squid in the
whale with the with the parent situation
no preferred that to just like more
dragons this way there's another dragon
coming for the south quick getting the
turret but the second one is Kit
Harington yeah yeah I'm also very
nervous cuz we're all on notice because
my wife loves these movies and she might
kill both of you oh well I'm sorry Tori
just just if anything bad I'm just know
that she's watching what's your dragon
back view they're cute and they look
really
okay good enough yeah there you go
you're safe alright well with that let's
get into my post trailer for how to
trains use dragons from the studio that
made a movie about a bee in an
interspecies relationship so we clearly
just dreamworks made a movie where a bee
falls in love with a lady
I mean he's a bee and she's a lady I
wasn't supposed to even work so what I
love is that Jerry hey this is it jerry
pitched b-movie himself so this was his
brainchild just took every studio at an
old timey car until someone was like
okay fine Jerry yeah no I think they
were just like Jerry Seinfeld wants to
make a cartoon with us yes sure
comedians and cars pitching movie things
up pitching be movies be movie movie
I've never seen it we talking about
How to Train Your Dragon 1 and to visit
the magical land of bird a place full of
happy buggies and happy dragons and when
they team up you can assume they'll
bring untold pain and carnage to the
rest of the world
so let's turn the dial back to
family-friendly to experience the saga
of an unlikely hero hiccup he didn't
inherit his father's Viking strength or
his Viking Scottish accent to placing
first and dragon trainer but he's buzzed
so Gerard Butler now has brought the
Scottish accent to Greece yes now to the
Viking the Vikings yeah
and defend it with the Opera it was
there and Dracula's there a little bit
so that's turn Europe yeah I think I
think we just have to accept that Gerard
Butler doesn't do accents very well
that's fair that's a fair point but
every other elder Viking has a Scottish
accent
Craig Ferguson Craig Ferguson has one
make up no elder like that skipped the
whole younger generation they all sound
like slight variations of maybe TJ
Miller and then maybe on the island that
was the accent and so it's like an
immigration thing where it's like their
parents still sound Scottish but they
sound like the locals the locals weird
because like I guess it's sort of
implied in the background that they're
still like a Viking raiding culture like
they're coming back from fishing trips
fishing like for other culture it's our
new maid I read a whole thing cuz I just
like I wanted to be airtight so that the
moment we're like the Scottish voice
like there weren't a million comments
like okay let's talk about the links
between Highlanders and Vikings and I
did read a whole thing that was like
maybe they're far enough north that it's
fine and also a Swedish accent would be
a little silly if they went with that
but it wasn't enough for me to be like
let's cut our funny Scottish jokes cuz
the funny Scottish jokes are good
I think the Swedish accent would have
been great
the children furniture do you think
there is an initial voice cast where
they were like let's go we want
authentic we're going full sweetie and
then they like listened to the apology
to Sweden Frost with all your favorite
cat videos
they'll prove that working together
makes people stronger and their
friendship will transform Berk from a
land that used to hate and fear dragons
to one that uses them for Quidditch or
something right QT is Oh strapped in as
hiccup teams up with his pals Astrid and
the Warriors for who have even less
character development than Siffin the
Warriors three like the boy why would
they cast at that time even now Jonah
Hill obviously still at that time the
first one Christopher mintz-plasse big
off of super bad and then you've got TJ
Miller all right up-and-comer and you
know good character though Kristen Wiig
right yeah yeah nothing with anybody
yeah any voice I guess cuz that was to
me that's like a junket casting it's
just like whenever there's some of the
character but man the junket that's
movie in that sense which is usually
like celebrity and pop-culture driven
even though the story is actually yeah
it and from it from a book yeah but the
books like it's like a big it's like a
15-page little thing they got it but
anyway yeah from a book yeah and then
they just go with the their fallback is
to get as many famous people do voices
as possible this is crazy look at fault
even by the second one like you would
think they would do more with that cast
but I mean it's easy money
oh yes for them which all in two hours
good work yeah but it just seems so
weird that they would have people like
really good talented people and if
nothing I guess to them and worth it
just to put their name on the poster
like the Sandia's me cheap thing where
it's like Oh cynthaiz meet you yeah
Jonah Hill's in this movie like it yeah
it probably pays for itself but yeah and
then for on the celebrity side it's like
you wanted you want a car
for a couple minutes of work a couple
hours yeah that's true I I get why they
took the work yeah yeah the car for two
hours of work would be wonderful
no I agree you know I mean they're there
for like every now and then today they
do a funny character bit and you could
have kind of probably just had anybody
yeah do that
right we get that can you name all of
them all of the characters yeah no snot
rod but rocket sure was nice not nut lug
Duggan rent get me market wrench tutor
yeah gear groper yeah
paper clip Tobin squeeze squeeze
I like ale whether it's discovering that
dragons are all true serving a bigger
dragon or that transients are on drones
serving a bigger dragon or that bigger
dragons can fight over who gets to make
dragons into drones serving a figure
dragon another there's actually very
little dragon training in the entire
franchise then again how to prevent the
submission of your dragon to the will of
a homicidal apex predator doesn't have
quite the same ring to it so we can toss
fantasy series dragon it seems like
really anyone can train a dragon they do
it so easily just no one ever thought to
try spend whatever thought to do the the
like Chris Pratt
Jurassic world like no one ever thought
to bring an open hand instead of a
closed fist and that's that's the beauty
of these films yeah but the title of
them is How to Train Your Dragon yeah
you're right all right I mean I would
say that toothless is trained in the
first one yeah he gets trained enough to
justify and then I think you're just
stuck with the title from then on
because it's not like yeah if you're
gonna like how to live with your dragon
for two it's as you lose that you lose
the you lose the snappiness of it yeah
it's a little like she doesn't kill bill
and kill bill one yeah but they still
called it that right yes
they did it I'll take that knowledge
although it is one movie it's intended
to be so are these is me when Quentin
Tarantino decides it's one movie when he
decides to add one more to the list of
movies because he made a proclamation
ten years ago just retro actively
combined continue this Pulp Fiction
Reservoir Dogs now cat was once a movie
yep yeah all my movies 101 movie you
think it's like usual pop-culture
references for some actual heart make
sure to check out some of the best
modern fantasy movies today what are we
gonna get yelled at the most well our
fight was Narnia well we took out the
first lie in the Witch of the Wardrobe
right yeah cuz I knew I saw that fight
comin Narnia one would yeah so we took
the one that we say is terrible that
people are gonna be like that wasn't
terrible I'm gonna say the Golden
Compass people are gonna come after us
oh no no the Golden Compass people hate
that but they do okay then the workers
say people like it's fine an ambitious
failure we shall take I'll give it a
good what what yeah I can't I mean I
don't I don't know any in the name of
the King stands I bet there's some
legend of the seeker people that are
just waiting for it to melts I will I
will fight them because they're gonna
have to fight the entire Eragon wiki
legend of the seeker is affront to the
darkest rising sequence yeah I just
regarding its the hobbits it's the hot
people be like it's so trendy to hate
the Hobbit train yeah we've got a lot of
defenders in our very own office though
we do we do we do we do here and have a
lot of hog yeah that's true
yeah our fight was the first Narnia
which I gave today and out of respect
very good I just saw I just it was to
get it sometimes you see you can you
pulling us all out of the way of a
speeding bus
it was was it was gonna be Christmas in
this office exactly that just was we
couldn't we couldn't do it I get it
thank you for saving us that time I'm
sure Lord most my Harry Potter movies or
terrible stuff How to Train Your Dragon
it's the best of what's left story
that's part do with whoever is Reagan
how to this is Scotland no army hammer
Lydia Dragonforce mother of dragons
Drago Jon Snow and no go on get out of
here of your dragons to the will of a
homicidal apex predator see not catchy
everyone knows I more irritating see
very true TJ Miller very true so I hear
um How to Train Your Dragon 3 is done
what no film has done before like
Deadpool 2 or red player one and got rid
of TJ Miller yeah I crossed my fingers
and checked the IMDB and they got a
sound-alike e interesting yeah yeah I
mean it's good work you like be fasting
was it fun drool yeah I honestly I think
that is that is something that voiceover
actors should mold themselves an
advertise like they should just be like
okay who's problematic as hell who's
just who's just waiting for their time
to come I'm gonna perfect my impression
of all the food oh that dude works for
life but usually it's the person you
don't anticipate so yeah we're just the
true Church favors the lucky yeah basis
yeah because who knows yeah yeah there
is but there's somebody who's like they
all told me this TJ Miller impression
was a waste of time
I just made boy sing mucus yeah Godfried
sound-alikes I was crazy don't work from
my Gilbert Gottfried's voice and now I'm
making about a tenth of what he made me
do this commercial is the video game in
Kingdom Hearts for when I go to a flick
doesn't land I got lunch for this yeah
yeah good good what should we work on
we'll discuss that off camera yeah it's
competition oh yeah bongos this is a
meme I didn't know about blonde said it
was huge story
HR buffing rough my best gal curry NPCs
bro huh mate a one-armed man hey this
guy's name is drago bludvist Wow
it's good it's here it's a cool name
it's a really cool name yeah we we cut
NPCs because we didn't have faith in our
audience to remember that an NPC is an
RPG term and not a all right Joe another
word for I'm so out of the loop I don't
know the out of the loop reference that
we could like I was double out of the
loop does it not even know what the
other side of the loop was in the right
places
yeah no you're in a good safe place well
anyways those were our thoughts on the
dragon training films I'm excited for
the third one I like that they keep like
aging up the characters yeah I kind of
dig that I we're really excited for it
we had managed to not see anything for
it and then you're watching something on
Hulu last night and the ad was just
here's a four-minute scene from
How to Train Your Dragon and and now
you're not seeing it anymore yeah
brilliant yeah it's completely ruined
movie
I was very upset that just came out of
nowhere did you not skip it no it was
just the the ad on Hulu you couldn't
look away I mean we did but it was just
like four minutes of lake four minutes
is a long time to sit on your couch
going back out and like try it again and
see if you got a different ad or I mean
the remote is like over there not
skippable four-minute ad they also
probably wanted to see it and they
probably couldn't look away cuz like you
gotta know what you can skip your ads on
Hulu sometimes I couldn't it's just a
4-minute ad that seems intense for a
long time as long as a whole see me yeah
it's very frustrating that's forward huh
well alright apologies to Joe's wife for
besmirching the good name of How to
Train Your Dragon it's okay you know
there's clearly fans of it I'll clear
things up when I get home okay so I hope
I didn't cause any trouble for you in
otherwise you know this is one of those
weeks there's like yeah these are nice
kids movies yeah for or adults or adults
or grown grown people you're made for
adults yes they were made yes not for
children they're made for me I own Star
Wars and I like I like this DreamWorks
made you know some some real movies I do
sometimes they're just like the
skeletons on which to hang joke meet
yeah and buy joke me I mean here's a
reference or something you remember
don't you yeah yeah otherwise How to
Train Your Dragon three would have had
just so many fortnight jokes and like
right there maybe one for tonight it's
probably in there somewhere
yeah some people do the Carlton yeah
someone's gonna floss you know someone's
flossing but no do we think a dragon is
flossing or a rider is passing her boat
Viking background Viking background
Viking class ground Viking maybe one of
the Warriors four it's gonna be the TJ
Miller one's gonna fly
look at this dance I learned I called a
bomb threat on a train once out but they
put in reference to these off-screen
troubles that's one way to go I would
not take that bet but I will bet on the
floss and yeah buzz like you're flossing
in the Toy Story Fort Robinson I think
one is I think one of the toys was floss
that movie's gonna be bad oh they
haven't they haven't let us down yet
I have faith but I worry the first like
the first thing I saw in Key & Peele
were just doing the Liam Neeson's guys
which by the way I would love them to do
a new Liam Neeson sketch now Liam Neeson
like I think that'd be a great sketch
but yeah the moment they were just doing
those characters pretty much in the
first Toy Story 4 trailer I was like
okay we'll see
see I just yeah I don't know there's so
much happiness enjoy that I'll give them
a benefit until I don't like me so I'm
predicting a finding Dory level that was
fine yeah yeah well well dreams die I'll
see you guys next week when we're doing
a more a more prestigious film I think
or maybe more a few yeah thanks for
stopping by honest trailer commentaries
we'll see you next time same time maybe
a different place could be
you
[Music]